foreign
[Music]
[Music]
help me
hola internet bienvenuto a lotiorio Del
sine today we're the show that needs
your help can you see the Subscribe
button
where click on it if you see it
there it is thanks for helping me out in
case you haven't figured it out today
we're heading out into the jungle and
talking about the Nickelodeon classic
Dora the Explorer for those of you who
haven't seen it the show is all about a
girl named Dora and her monkey friend
boots Dora is trying to get somewhere in
every episode and the viewer has to help
Dora by screaming at the television in
both English and Spanish because let's
face it she never sees anything do you
see the bananas it is right there Dora
right there are you even trying you just
turn around the twist is that the whole
show is presented as an old school
educational point-and-click video game
kind of like Putt-Putt or Pajama Sam
though looking at the animation here it
looks a bit closer to those old awful
Zelda CDI games gee it sure is boring
around here my boy but of course it
couldn't be a video game without some
sort of obstacle in the player's way
other than simple puzzle solving the
main thing that keeps Dora and Boots
from proceeding is a fox named swiper so
named because he likes stealing their
stuff
Box is always trying to swipe our stuff
and just like everything else in the
show Dora doesn't ever see swiper coming
so we the viewer are left screaming at
our TVs whatever swiper shows up like
Walter yelling at Jesse thankfully
stopping swiper and his tracks is super
easy all Dora Boots and the viewer have
to do is politely ask him to stop three
times
oh man yep swiper just snaps his fingers
and gives up kind of like he's thinking
well what else am I gonna do they asked
me to stop after all but something about
swiper that's always bothered me is that
this strategy actually works without
fail just standing there and repeating
Swiper no swiping a few times gets him
to stop and just go away it is strange
especially if this is a video game even
if we assume that the viewer is supposed
to be playing the Dora game and also
telling swiper to scram that's not
really a game mechanic that I've seen
before and believe me I have seen a lot
of game mechanics through my years
theorizing over at our sister location
Game Theory you see loyal theorists I
believe that there's a dark secret
hidden under swiper's adorable little
thief mask like why does that fox need
to remain anonymous who is going to
recognize one specific [ __ ] oh we aren't
dealing with just one specific Fox here
or even a cute anthroporophized video
game one either no despite Dora the
Explorer appearing to be a harmless
educational kids show on the surface its
mischievous Fox villain is actually a
demonic Spirit from he double hockey
sticks what's more Dora's Swiper no
swiping chant is her desperate attempt
to Ward him off but sadly swipers
trapped Dora in a fate worse than death
oh yeah it's gonna be one of those
episodes friends can you say secret dark
Lore
great then let's jump to it to begin why
would I possibly think that swiper could
potentially be a demon well first off
foxes are often depicted as Spirits by
cultures all over the world in West
Africa the dogon people believe that
their trickster God is a Pale Fox
Japanese Legend tells of shape-shifting
fox Spirits called Kitsune in classic
Greek mythology the god of wine and
fertility Dionysus often sends a giant
Fox to Devour the children of Thieves
seems a bit extra for a god of wine and
fertility but then I saw that Dionysus
was also the God of Insanity so yeah it
checks out anyway you get the idea foxes
are commonly associated with magic in
all sorts of folklore but still why
would I possibly think that could apply
to swiper in this particular instance
well swiper's depiction in the show
lines up real well with two types of
evil Fox Spirits in particular both of
which Dora would be aware of based on
where the character comes from while we
can't be sure exactly where Dora
originates we can get a pretty good idea
thanks to how she was designed according
to Nickelodeon they didn't want Dora to
be from any specific country because
they wanted all latino children to be
able to see themselves within the
character so instead Dora was developed
to be Pam Latina representative of the
diversity of Latino cultures across
Latin America and wouldn't you know it
but several Native American and Central
American cultures have foxes featured
prominently in their folklore mostly as
tricksters thieves and bad Omens in one
very specific example the zil Mayan
people of what's now modern-day Mexico
saw the Fox as a very evil animal so
since Dora is meant to be a mishmash of
all those varied Latino cultures she'd
likely be aware of these sorts of
stories additionally since we know that
Dora was created to represent the entire
region of Latin America we can look at
the breakdown of religious affiliation
across the region and see that 90 of
Latin Americans are Christian with 69
percent of them being Catholic so Dora
would likely also be familiar with how
Christianity and specifically the
Catholic church has viewed foxes in the
past and uh let's just say that
Catholicism has not been kind to these
Critters in fact one of the most famous
Catholic depictions of foxes has them
literally stealing important items I
suppose you could say that they were
swiping them in the 8th century author
Rudolph afolda wrote the book life of
leoba chronicling the Roman Catholic
saint none leoba the book tells of a nun
who once lost the keys to her Chapel
convinced that the Lost keys were the
work of the devil the chapel nuns
gathered in another building Enchanted
prayers for their return soon after a
fox was found dead outside the front
gate of the church with the keys in its
mouth a fox with stolen Keys you say
seems familiar
you're too late yep literally in the
first episode of the first season of
Dora the Explorer swiper steals Keys
it's one of the very first things that
we see this character do if that wasn't
intentional well it is certainly one
heck of a coincidence and that's not all
apparently old school Christianity saw
foxes as even worse than simple thieves
we know this thanks to a 13th century
book called The bestiary which was
basically like a strategy guide for
medieval knights to know which animals
were gonna give him the most experience
points Christians of the era saw many
animals as representative of moral
ideals or failures and the bestiary was
a collection of this sort of knowledge
cranes for instance represented
Guardians that brought physical Goods to
the needy you want to take a guess as to
what foxes represented literally the
devil yep just under very helpful tips
like the fox being a deceitful animal
that never runs in a straight line the
bestiary tells us that foxes represent
demons that trick and harm those who
have wavered in their faith basically
their are huge parts of Dora's likely
upbringing that would have been telling
her that swiper isn't just a sneaky fox
trying to steal her stuff he's a demonic
Spirit perhaps even the Devil Himself
come to haunt her as she goes about on
her adventures which makes it
interesting to see what dora does when
she and Boots confront swiper in the
shower in Boots and the viewer if you
choose to participate extend a handout
and chant the words Swiper no swiping
you want to know what that resembles an
exorcism now before you rush down to the
comments and say matpat that is a bit of
a stretch trust me I know it is but for
as ridiculous as it sounds what Dora's
doing here is an exact description of
some types of exorcisms first of all
according to of exorcisms and certain
supplications which was written by the
Vatican and approved by the pope
exorcists are instructed to extend their
hands out towards the possessed person
or demon during the Ritual from there
they're told to use a spiritual
incantation based basically chanting a
rhythmic word or phrase over and over to
force the spirits to behave finally
using swiper's name is also a practice
specifically used in exorcisms according
to Cesar trukui an exorcist for the
Catholic Church of Switzerland quote
naming something or knowing its name
means having power over that thing so by
specifically calling out swiper Dora is
giving herself power over him most
importantly of all like I mentioned
earlier this actually works for some
reason it always gets swiper to go away
okay so that's a lot of evidence
pointing to swiper being some sort of
demonic Spirit but why what does it
matter if swiper is some sort of
Supernatural otherworldly entity if it's
all happening inside of a video game the
whole exorcism chanting as a game
mechanic still doesn't make a ton of
sense and some like just getting the
player to click on swiper to stop him
would work a lot better and it's not
like we see a mic set up on the computer
inside the show the vocal input of the
player saying Swiper no swiping just
wouldn't work with what we've seen all
around this chanting mechanics just
seems like a weird thing to the program
into your game unless of course it
wasn't programmed and Swiper is an
actual literal Spirit that's possessing
the computer then it all starts to make
sense the chanting the lack of a
microphone to hear that chanting and the
chanting working to scare swiper away
but then all of this raises a whole
bunch of other questions like why would
swiper be bothering us if he's actually
a spirit I'm sure a trickster demon
would have better things to do than make
it a bit harder for a kid playing a
point-and-click adventure game to beat a
level right well what if it's not us the
viewer that swiper is trying to mess
with what if his Target is actually Dora
now that wouldn't make a ton of sense if
she were just some character in a video
game but I don't think she is just some
character in a video game I suspect that
Dora is actually a real person someone
who is sucked into the video game
trapped by swiper as he torments her
over and over again episode after
episode after episode at first blush
that might seem ridiculous but the
evidence is actually there when you look
right from the very beginning of each
episode in the intro we see clues that
Dora might not actually be a part of the
game in the first few seasons door of
the Explorer opens with a brief live
action segment entering a house walking
up to a computer and starting to play
the Dora the Explorer game but something
seems off when you actually think about
what's inside of this room sure you have
a lot of stuff that you'd expect some
sports balls a teddy bear a chain of
those paper rings that everyone makes in
elementary school and at the desk we can
see figurines of both swiper and Boots
the main animal characters from the game
so we know that this door of the
Explorer game exists in the world enough
so that there's merch to buy but you
ever notice what isn't in the room merch
of Dora herself you know the flagship
character of both the game and this show
all about playing that game the only
thing that even comes close to
resembling Dora in the room is this
child's drawing that I guess kinda
resembles her either way it seems
strange that whomever lives here is a
big enough fan of Dora to leave it
running on their computer so they can
decide to run into the room and play it
at any moment but then to not have any
merch of the main character speaking of
is also a weird detail here right no one
in the room it's deserted and yet the
computer was left on with the Dora game
booted up ready to play what if what
we're walking into with the intro here
is the direct aftermath of Dora being
sucked into the computer forced to play
the game in person for the amusement of
a certain little fox demon now those
details about the intro might seem
circumstantial on their own but the
weirdness only continues when you start
to consider the ending credits early on
in the history of the show a lot adore
the Explorer's endings featured small
little mini games while the credits
rolled the most common of these was
character find which is pretty much
exactly what it says on the tin a list
of characters would pop up and the
computer cursor would pick one and then
they would hide putting their head out
as the cursor tried to find them now the
characters that pop up for this are
largely what you'd expect main
characters like Boots and Swiper
recurring characters like Benny and map
even characters who only guest star like
Wizzle and yet across the 88 times that
this minigame pops up can you guess who
isn't chosen Dora despite supposedly
being the starring character in the game
she's not chosen once for the character
find minigame heck though she appears on
the logo for the select screen I think
you could argue that she was never even
an option to begin with and it's not
like the character find is against
choosing human characters either it had
no problem choosing Santa Claus in the
episode where he gets starred freaking
Santa Claus was chosen before Dora it's
a strange decision that starts to make
sense when you consider that Dora isn't
a character inside the game she was
never chosen because she shouldn't exist
in this world the game wasn't programmed
to have her selectable as an option but
wait I hear you saying what about that
live-action Door movie that came out a
few years ago Dora and the lost city of
gold it was way better than it had any
right to be and correct you are a random
commenter it was really solid but I
understand what you're trying to get at
here the beginning of Dora and the lost
city of gold really frames a lot of the
Fantastical adventure Dora goes on as
Just Happening inside of her head so
that means that our demon Spirit fox in
a video game theory can't be right right
wrong go watch that movie again because
if anything it's solidified is that Dora
is a real person trapped inside of a
video game right near the beginning Dora
straight up breaks the fourth wall
saying can you
can use your soul
yeah Dora can clearly see us the
audience and yet no one else can she is
aware that she's in a game despite
everyone else trying to convince her
that she's not almost like it's a fox
demon gaslighting her she'll grow out of
it monkeys can't swing and climb and
talk to us no they can't Booth isn't
talking to you oh but he can you're not
a kid but you're not a grown-up either
Dora anything is possible and he's not
the only animal who does either swipers
in this movie tormenting Dora and her
friends and guess what he can talk too
swiper at the ready swiper yes swiping
make no mistake this movie is still
existing inside the realm of the Dora
video game I mean there are a ton of
video game elements here
yeah and that bag holds way more stuff
than it should a generator a radio Food
Supplies a hammock a giant knife to the
point that this thing has to be bigger
on the inside than the outside just like
a video game inventory and it's not just
cool video gamey items either multiple
times throughout the film Dora does
stuff that should get a normal person
killed like jumping into a ravine with
minimal injuries or sliding under a
plane's moving propeller blade or
rolling down a hill inside of a tree
trunk she also solves puzzles in order
to progress and disarms booby traps in
order to get treasure the gang even
takes part in What basically amounts to
some quick time events to avoid spikes I
thought it was just a video game thing
you're right forgettable side character
it's just the video game from Dora's
perspective inside the computer and
we're just seeing everything through her
eyes that's why everything looks so
realistic and the extra bit of proof the
cherry on top the final nail in the
coffin there's a moment where the
illusion completely shatters about
halfway through the movie Dora and her
friend stumble upon a field of flowers
that spray hallucinogenic spores in
their face beginning a sequence that's
done in the style of a classic Dora
cartoon and during this sequence she
straight up jumps off a cliff and then
reappears again at the very top just
like she respawned after dying this my
friends is the mask slipping from the
Demonic computer program revealing to
Dora what's really going on here she is
a real person trapped in an old
point-and-click video game really we
should have known something was fishy
from the movie right at the beginning
what do we see right at the beginning of
Dora and the lost city of gold Fox
propaganda swiper trying to Gaslight us
the audience just like he's gaslighting
her literally the first thing that
happens in the movie is a helpful
totally true PSA from the fox Council of
the Americas which tells us this
everything you're about to see is true
except that foxes don't swipe that is a
hurtful stereotype oh yeah well I'd say
that trapping a kid inside of a video
game and tormenting her for years is
just a wee bit more hurtful swiper but
hey you know you don't have to be
trapped inside of a video game tormented
by a box demon to be completely immersed
inside of something sometimes you just
want to get lost in listening to a good
movie or your favorite music I have to
listen to a lot of content while doing
research for this show interviews
audiobooks podcasts you name it I am
listening to it and our sponsor for
today's episode raycon's everyday
earbuds are the best way to do that on
the go something I hate about other
earbuds is that they never quite seem to
fit my ear right they always fall out at
the worst times and then I have to stop
I have to find them and then I have to
hope that they're not too gross to stick
back in my ear but raycon's earbuds have
these awesome little gel tips that are
super optimized to fit in your ear so
not only are they comfy they're not
gonna budge believe me I tried I
simultaneously whipped and nae nade and
they didn't move an inch plus the
earbuds have eight hours of charge in
them the charging case holds an
additional 32 hours of battery so you
don't have to plug these bad boys into
the wall every single night and even
when they do need to charge you don't
have to worry about cords tangling you
up thanks to their new wireless charging
feature what's crazy to me is that
raycon's been able to pack so much
quality into the every day earbuds
there's great stereo sound they
passively block out background noise so
I can focus on my work I don't even need
to look at my phone when I want to
switch tracks change the volume or
answer a call I can do all of it with a
simple tap thanks to raycon's touch
controls and all of that at an awesome
price that's like half of what the other
premium audio Brands offer so if you're
looking for a new pair of earbuds and
you want to get them at an even better
deal than what they normally offer click
the link in the description below or go
to buy recon.com film Theory
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y to get yourself 15
off your order that's byracon.com
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y to get yourself 15
off they're already incredibly low price
that is top tier quality without
sacrifice in your pocketbook and in the
meantime friends remember it's all just
a theory a film Theory and cuts